okay so at the end of the show one
audience member is gonna earn time in
the booth
[Applause]
and today we've got a twist all the
questions will come from a very special
guest in our digital hub neil patrick
harris yes
how fun is that
neil is here he's in the building i've
been hanging out with him all morning
and he is going to run the pop quiz yes
the best of the best neil so pay close
attention to everything he says because
today's pop quiz is based on what he's
telling you all right and he's a master
of games by the way he has an amazing
game called box one it's a board game i
cannot recommend it enough
and then um he has this new movie coming
out called 8-bit christmas and it kind
of reminds me of like a christmas carol
it's really good for kids and adults
it's going to be an instant classic i'm
super excited he's here today he's all
day with us yes i know so cool
so one of the best things about the
holiday is the food and my husband david
is an amazing chef and one of my
favorite dishes that he makes are
cookies he makes these peanut butter
cookies where he makes it they're small
and puts a divot in it and then he puts
a mini peanut butter cup inside while
it's warm and it melts over the top and
then it hardens
wow they're delicious we absolutely love
the holidays at our house we go all out
here's a cool thing that i found i like
to project
images onto our house and i found these
disco balls that are inside a box and a
light shines on them and they slowly
rotate and it looks like it's snowing
on the side of the house you put two
together less of a disco party and more
of like a dispersed snow effect
disco balls
this holiday season we have a daytime
exclusive to share with you it's a sneak
peek of neil patrick harris's new movie
that i mentioned earlier 8-bit christmas
which premieres november 24th on hbo max
and keep your eyes peeled for a special
message from neil because remember
we got a pop quiz that's right hello
we'll be right back
congratulations
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
mine
was nintendo
no nintendo on my house looks like a
no-go on nintendo i needed a christmas
miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowl was in it okay does it really
matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s this is
bigger than christmas this is our
vietnam i don't think that means what
you think it means i have no idea what
it means we're gonna get in so much
trouble
first prize is a brand new nintendo
there are no rules
hold on
video games have been doing all kinds of
strange things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real hey
everyone it's neil patrick harris how
are you thanks for watching the trailer
for 8-bit christmas happy holidays i'm
so excited for you to see it i love the
gift-giving season last year
we
gave via our friend santa claus a gift
to our kids the gift of a golden
retriever puppy her name is ella
and little known fact her middle name
is menope so if you put them together
her name is ella menope
you're welcome
[Music]